สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมกราคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
[เพลง]
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวันนี้วันศุกร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 27 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมกราคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 29
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมกราคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ 2023
ตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
6 โมง
6 โมงเช้าหรือว่า 6 โมงเย็น
6 โมงเช้าค่ะ
6 โมงเช้ากี่นาทีค่ะ
6 โมง 51 นาทีนะคะครูฟ้า
ตื่นแล้วใช่ไหมคะ
ครูฟ้าตื่นกี่เปอร์เซ็นต์ผู้หญิงฟังจาก
เสียงแล้วน่าจะตื่นประมาณ 0.01%
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะเพราะว่า 6 โมงเช้าประเทศไทย
เนี่ย
6 โมงเช้าประเทศไทยก็อาจจะเป็น 6 โมง
เย็น
ที่อเมริกาก็ได้เออ
ครูฟ้า
ต้องไอก่อนนะคะ
ใช่แล้วค่ะนักเรียน
6 โมงเช้าที่ไทยเนี่ยง่วง
แต่ 6 โมงเย็น 6 โมงเช้าที่ไทย 6 โมงเย็น
ประเทศนักเรียนหรือออสเตรเลียก็อาจจะแบบ
3 ทุ่ม 4 ทุ่มวันนี้ครูหญิงไม่แน่ใจนะคะ
แล้วก็ได้นักเรียนก็กำลังจะนอนแล้วใช่ไหม
เพราะว่านักเรียนเนี่ยรอฟังพูดทุกวีดีโอ
นะคะ
เล่านิทาน
เล่านิทานครูฟ้ามีนิทานมาเล่าให้ฟัง
ว่ามีนิทานนะคะ
นักเรียนบอกว่าขอ 1 เรื่องวิดีโอนี้ขอให้
ครูฟานเล่าให้ฟัง 1 เรื่องได้ไหม
ได้ๆๆๆ
แล้ววันนี้ครูฟ้าจะเล่านิทานเรื่องอะไรคะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะ
จะเล่านิทานเรื่อง
หูอะไรเนี่ย
แมวเหรอคะเมี้ยวๆ
มีคิ้วมีคิ้วด้วยมีตา
มีอะไรคะ
[เพลง]
นักเรียน
วันนี้ครูฟ้าจะเล่านิทานเรื่องสิงโตเหรอ
คะ
สิงโตอ้าวๆๆ
ไก่
สิงโตกับไก่หรอคะสิงโตไก่และก็
อันนี้หูอะไรเนี่ยหูยาวมาก
นักเรียนคิดว่าตัวอะไรคะ
ครูหญิงยังไม่รู้เลยนะคะว่าตัวอะไร
อันนี้ตาของมันแน่ๆจมูกแน่ๆ
ปากรู้ไหมว่าตัวอะไร
ตัวอะไรคะ
ปลา
นะ
คะนี่คือนิทานที่ครูฟ้าจะมาเล่าให้นัก
เรียนฟังในวันนี้ใช่ค่ะนิทานชื่อสิงโตไก่
และหลานนะคะ
แล้วเรื่องมันเป็นยังไงคะครูฟ้า
เรื่องก็มีอยู่ว่า
ไก่
กับปลาเนี่ย
ไก่กับลายอยู่ด้วยกันหรอ
อยู่บ้านเดียวกันเหรอคะเดี๋ยวจะเปิดรูป
Line ให้ดูนะคะเปิดนักเรียนคิดเองมันคือ
ตัวอะไร
ได้ค่ะ
ไก่กับปลาเนี่ยนะคะนักเรียนเป็นเพื่อนกัน
นี่ไง
ผู้หญิงเก่งมากค่ะ
ไก่กับร้านเนี่ยเป็นเพื่อนกัน
เป็นเพื่อนกันนะคะแล้วยังไงต่อคะ
เป็นเพื่อนรักกันนะวันนึงเนี่ย
คือไก่กับลานยังมีบ้านอยู่ด้วยกันนะคะ
เป็นเพื่อนรักกันค่ะอยู่บ้านเดียวกันถ้า
อยู่บ้านเดียวกันนะคะแล้วก็
นอนด้วยกันกินด้วยกันทุกวันเลยนะคะและ
มีอยู่วันนึงไก่กับปลานี้ก็เดินเดิน
เดินไปหาอาหาร
ไก่กับลายกินอาหารเหมือนกันเหรอคะ
ลากินหญ้าไม่ใช่เหรอคะเนี่ยดูจากในรูป
เนี่ยใช่ไหมลากินหญ้า
ไก่เนี่ยกินหนอนไหมหนอน
แต่มันก็เดินไปในป่าไงที่มีต้นไม้ต้นไม้
เยอะๆเนี่ยในป่าก็มีหนอนมีหญ้าลากับไก่ก็
เดินไปหาอาหารด้วยกันได้ค่ะ
แล้วเป็นยังไงต่อคะ
ลากับไก่ด้วยนะคะก็ไปหาอาหารกินค่ะ
ระหว่างที่กำลังกินอาหารอยู่นี่นะคะเอา
บ้านเอา
[เพลง]
ก็มีสิงโตตัวนึง
หน้าตาน่ากลัว
สิงโต
เห็นลากับไก่หรอหรือว่าแอบดู
หรือว่าเดินมาหรือว่านอนหลับสิงโตอะไรคะ
เนี่ย
สิงโตนะ
แอบมองลากับไก่กินอาหาร
แอบมองแอบมองแอบมองแล้วคิดอะไรไหม
คิดว่า
ถ้ากินไก่เนี่ยนะคะนักเรียน
กินไก่เนี่ย
ไม่ดี
ทำไม
อร่อย
เอาผู้หญิงคิดว่าสิงโตสำหรับสิงโตเล็ก
ดีกว่า
กินล่ะ
แล้วสิงโตเนี่ยวิ่งไปแล้วก็
จับลามากินได้ไหม
ไม่ค่ะสิงโตไม่วิ่ง
แต่สิงโตเนี่ยนะคะย่องค่ะผู้หญิง
ย่องค่อยๆเดินเบาๆไม่ให้ลากับไก่เนี่ยได้
ยินใช่ไหม
สิงโตค่อยๆย่องไปที่ไหนคะครูฟ้าสิงโต
เนี่ยนะคะย่องไปหาลาค่ะคิดเดินไปข้างหลัง
ใช่ไหม
เดินไป
แต่ว่าโชคดีค่ะผู้หญิงไก่เนี่ยหันไปเห็น
พอดี
ของไก่หันไปก็ลาสิงโตอยู่ข้างหลัง
สิงโตอยู่ข้างหลังพอไก่เห็นเนี่ยไก่ก็เลย
ร้องค่ะ
ร้องเสียงดังๆเลยนะคะ
พอลาได้ยินไก่ร้องเนี่ยปลาก็ตกใจ
ร้านน่าจะฟังไก่เข้าใจนะ
ว่าถ้าไก่ร้องต้องมีอะไรแน่ๆเลย
ลาก็เลยร้องด้วยนะแบบร้องลาร้องยังไงคะ
นักเรียน
เค้าก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันนะ
คะครูฟ้าเสียงดังเหมือนกันค่ะพอเวลาร้อง
เนี่ยนะคะเสียงดังไก่ก็ร้องเสียงดัง
สิงโตก็เลยตกใจ
ถึงตัวที่กำลังย่องมาอยู่ข้างหลังเนี่ยนะ
ใช่ค่ะตกใจค่ะสิงโตก็เลยคิด
ไก่กับปลาร้องเสียงดังกินไม่ได้แล้ว
หมีดีกว่า
ใช่สิงโตก็เลยวิ่งหนีไปนะคะ
ลากับไก่เนี่ยก็ยังร้องอยู่ปลาเนี่ยพอ
เห็นสิงโตวิ่งหนีไป
ลาก็คิดว่า
สิงโตกลัวเราใช่ไหม
เพราะว่าสิงโตเห็นลาวร้องแล้ววิ่งหนีก็
น่าจะกลัวถ้าไม่กลัว
ทำไมวิ่งหนีไป
ลาคิดได้ยังไง
คิดว่าสิงโตเนี่ย
ก็เลยวิ่งหนี
พอเห็นแบบนั้นเนี่ยลาก็คิด
ฉันน่ากลัวใช่ไหม
สิงโตกลัวฉันแต่ว่าฉันแข็งแรงมากกว่า
สิงโตใช่ค่ะลาก็เลยวิ่งตามสิงโตค่ะนัก
เรียน
อ๋อเหมือนเวลาที่
เรากลัวอะไรแล้วเราวิ่งหนีแล้วมีคนวิ่ง
ตามอย่างนี้ใช่ไหมเราก็จะหนีๆๆๆๆๆว่าเรา
กลัว
ใช่สิงโตก็วิ่งหนีๆๆลาก็วิ่งตามสิงโตนะคะ
เพราะจะได้ทำให้สิงโตกลัวมากๆใช่ไหมสายตา
ก็นี้นะคะนี่ขาลานะคะอันนี้ขาสิงโตกำลัง
วิ่งวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งวิ่ง
สิงโตเนี่ยพอวิ่งไปสักพักเห็นปลาวิ่งตาม
มา
สิงโตคิดอะไรคะตอนที่หันไปแล้วเห็นลา
เนี่ยวิ่งตามสิงโตมาสิงโตก็เลยคิดว่าถ้า
อย่างนั้นเนี่ยนะ
วิ่งเข้าไปในป่าดีกว่า
[เพลง]
นักเรียนต้นไม้ต้นไม้ต้นไม้
ที่ที่มีต้นไม้เพราะว่าสิงโตอยู่ในป่าไง
ใช่ไหมคะ
สิงโตเนี่ยก็เลยวิ่งไปในป่า
คิด
ก็ไม่ได้ป่าลึกเลยเพราะไปไกลๆเลย
แบบว่าวิ่งเข้ามาในป่าแล้วก็เข้าไปเข้าไป
เข้าไป
เราบอกว่าไปในป่าไกลมากนะคะนักเรียนอ๋อ
เวลาเข้าไปในป่าไกลๆเนี่ยก็อาจจะมีสัตว์
นิดหน่อยถ้าไก่ก็วิ่งตามมาไม่ทันเหมือน
กัน
ตัวเล็กๆไงวิ่งตามมาไม่ทันสิงโตก็วิ่งๆๆ
เข้าไปในป่าลาก็ยังวิ่งตาม
สิงโตก็เลยเข้ามาที่นี่นะคะไกลมาก
พอลาวิ่งตามมาถึงเนี่ย
สิงโตทำยังไง
สัตว์นิดหน่อยนะคะ
อาจจะมีช้างช้าง
ไม่น่าจะไม่มี
มี
ก็น่าจะไม่มีอาจจะมีนก
หน่อยเพราะว่าปลาเนี่ยมันลึกมากๆ
ครูฟ้าไม่ได้ยินเสียงค่ะ
สิงโตก็เลยหันไปจับลามากินนะคะนั่งเรียน
เพราะว่าเราวิ่งตามสิงโตมาก
[เพลง]
ก็คือสิงโตเนี่ยแอบดูลาอยากกินหลายแล้วก็
วิ่งหนีลาวิ่งตามแล้วก็เลยโดนกิน
แล้วนิทานเรื่องนี้บอกอะไรคะ
ฟังจบแล้วเนี่ย
เพราะว่าลาเนี่ยนะคะนักเรียน
ลบก่อน
ลาเนี่ยคิดว่าตัวเองเก่ง
ใช่ไหม
ก็เลยวิ่งตามสิงโตนะคะแต่ไม่ได้รู้เลยว่า
จริงๆแล้วเนี่ยสิงโตเก่งกว่า
ก็คือจริงๆแล้ว
ลาเนี่ยไม่ได้ดูว่าทำไมทำไมสิงโตเนี่ย
วิ่งหนีลา
[เพลง]
เห็นแล้วก็คิดเองใช่ไหมว่าสิงโตเนี่ยวิ่ง
หนีลาเพราะว่ากลัวลา
ไม่ได้ดูว่าสิงโตเนี่ยวิ่งหนีลาเพราะว่า
มันเสียงดัง
อีกว่าทำไมสิงโตวิ่งหนีลาคิดเองว่า
สิงโตกลัวแล้วพอสิงโตวิ่งเข้าไปในป่าลึกๆ
ๆ
วิ่งเข้ามาในป่าลึกขนาดนี้
แล้วฉันไม่รู้จักป่า
แล้วฉันจะทำยังไง
ใช่ไหมล่ะก็คิดวิ่งตามใช่ค่ะนี่แหละ
ลาเนี่ย IQ ไม่โอเค EQ ไม่โอเคเพราะคิด
ว่าตัวเองเนี่ยนะคะเก่ง
เพราะฉะนั้นนิทานอันนี้ก็สอนว่าถ้าเราคิด
ว่าเราเก่งที่สุดมันจะทำให้เราเนี่ยโง่
อดัมแกรนด์บอกไว้นะคะ
ว่าตัวเองเก่งคนที่คิดว่าตัวเองเก่งเนี่ย
นะคะจะทำอะไรไม่โอเคหรอก
[เพลง]
ถ้าครูหญิงคิดว่าครูหญิงเก่งที่สุดเวลา
ที่คุยหญิงทำอะไรผิดแล้วครูฟ้าบอกครูหญิง
ครูหญิงพูดภาษาอังกฤษคำนี้ผิดนะแต่ครู
หญิงเก่งที่สุดแล้วไงผู้หญิงก็คิดผู้หญิง
เก่งผู้หญิงจะพูดผิดได้ยังไงใช่ผู้หญิงก็
ไม่ฟังแล้วผู้หญิงก็ไปพูดคนที่ฟังคุณหญิง
ก็แบบ
ทำไมพูดภาษาอังกฤษผิดแบบผิดแบบผิด 100%
นะคะ Meaning ก็เปลี่ยนอย่างนี้ครูฟ้า
เนี่ยบอกบอกแต่ผู้หญิงคิดว่าตัวเองเก่งก็
ไม่ฟังใครเลยใช่
ไหมไม่ดีค่ะคน EQ ไม่ดีไอคิวไม่ดีไม่เป็น
ไรนะคะนักเรียนบางคนไม่รู้ก็ไม่เป็นไรใช่
ไหมแต่คิดว่าตัวเองเก่งเนี่ยไม่โอเคนะคะ
ที่สุด
คิดว่าตัวเองเก่งคิดว่าตัวเองรู้ทั้งหมด
แล้วรู้มากที่สุดก็ไม่ฟังเวลามีคนบอกใช่
ไหมเหมือนลาไงลาคิดว่าตัวเองเก่งก็โดน
สิงโตกิน
คือเรารู้อันนี้ครูหญิงรู้ 1 เรื่องครู
ฟ้ารู้ 1 เรื่องครูหญิงไม่รู้เรื่องที่
ครูฟ้ารู้ก็ไม่ใช่ผู้หญิง IQ ไม่ดีใช่ไหม
ใช่
มันไม่เป็นไรนะคะถ้าเราไม่รู้ก็โอเคก็แค่
คิดโอเคฉันไม่รู้ไม่รู้ก็ถามใช่ไหมถามครู
ฟ้าครูหญิงไม่รู้ว่ารูปยังไงครูฟ้าบอกได้
ไหมโอเคแต่ไม่ใช่ผู้หญิงคิดซึ่งฉันวาดรูป
เก่ง
ฉันทำทุกอย่างเก่งฉัน I  Am  The  Best
อย่างนี้อันนี้ไม่โอเคนะคะไม่มีใครรู้
ทั้งหมดนี่ก็เป็นนิทานนะคะอย่าเป็นเหมือน
ลานะคะเราต้องเป็นเหมือนไก่นะคะ
แล้วเจอกันวีดีโอหน้าสวัสดีค่ะ